now relive some iconic vegas nostalgia
circus circus is welcoming families and
thrill seekers back to the adventure
dome and
rocky is giving us a sneak peek of all
the safe fun that you can have
yes we are here at the adventure dome in
circus circus you guys know and love
this place and it is
back after being shut down well
okay the ride is starting vice president
of attractions
tell us what we're on because this was
the only thing i had enough courage to
ride
we're on the bc bus which is one of our
family rides okay
and we have 25 rides and attractions in
the park we have something for everybody
even for you
even thank you tom i appreciate that
i've had a little trouble since i turned
30 everybody
with roller coasters and hoops and
things i don't know what changed
is it just age age we just uh we can't
do like the little kids the little kids
can do this all day long
they're the bravest we love we love the
kids we love the kids here at adventure
dome so let's talk since we're on the
school bus
let's let's educate everybody what are
some of the frequently asked questions
that you get about the adventure dome
now that we're back open they want to
know how fast the roller coaster goes
which goes 55 miles an hour they want to
know how many rides and attractions we
have we have 25 rides and attractions
okay
uh they want to know how many people
come through every year and we average
about 3.5 million people wow
per year uh once regular business
okay guys gotcha and obviously
there's some safety protocol in place
i've seen masks i see small groups so
what's that what's going on with that
uh you don't have to ride with any
strangers you ride with the people that
you come in with
we get extra cleaning uh constant
sanitation we have santa stage
sanitation stations all throughout the
park so it's a
nice clean safe fun environment for
everybody that is exactly
what we need nowadays so thank you so
much time for everything you're doing
for the community
um new spring break hours obviously 12
to midnight 12 to midnight for spring
break
we have our brand new ride the nebula
that's we're all excited oh yeah that's
out there do you see it
yeah not getting on that fyi
and we have new rides and attractions uh
coming uh
coming soon okay so something we all
know and love but it's ever evolving and
it constantly just gets better and
better
i love it thank you so much thank you
very much i'll send it back to you guys
thank you rocky stay safe out there we
will check back in with her during the
four o'clock newscast